The square quantity is isolated on one side of our equation. So, we can take
the square root of this side and this side. The square root undoes the square,
leaving us with m plus 2 on the left, and positive or negative root 36 on the
right. We know the square root of 36 is just 6. So we have this equation next.
We subtract 2 from both sides, to get m is equal to negative 2, plus or minus
6. When we have this equation, m equals negative 2, plus or minus 6, we really
have 2 equations. M could equal negative 2 plus 6, or m could equal negative 2
minus 6. There's really 2 values of m here. And since these are like terms, we
can simplify. So m could equal positive 4 or m could equal negative 8. These
were the two solutions.